the Queen canceling events local
elections delayed a year meanwhile the
World Health Organization declare your
the epicenter of the pandemic five
thousand people have lost their lives
a tragic milestone Europe has now become
the epicenter of the pandemic with more
reported cases and deaths than the rest
of the world combined
apart from China the nation looking to
the decisions of this man with advisers
explaining possibly the most important
call he will ever make to delay the
shutdown of schools workplaces and big
events if you completely locked down
absolutely everything probably for a
period of four months or more then you
would suppress this virus all of the
evidence from previous epidemics suggest
that when you do that and then you
release it it all comes back again so
the other part of this is to make sure
that we don't end up with a sudden peak
again in the winter 60% is the sort of
figure you need to get hurt herd
immunity but some experts questioned the
conclusions which government scientists
have drawn we don't know whether or not
this virus induces very effective herd
immunity if you take rubella most
children get rubella if they haven't had
the vaccine and they would have lifelong
immunity if you get the flu next year
you need a different vaccine because the
strain is different which camp is
coronavirus in we don't yet know the
opposition isn't opposing but not quite
sure how far to support either I support
the approach of moving from the
contained stage to the delay stage but I
think the government needs to move to
the explained stage I just want the
government to be clearer with the public
I've got constituents asking me wine
football games are not being cancelled
they're asking me serious questions
about how their elderly relatives are
going to cope because we know the social
care system has been so cut back after
many many years that asking me questions
about schools when they see other
countries across the world closing
schools Boris Johnson's government has
struck out on its own
internationally at least in its handling
of the coronavirus crisis now so far
Boris Johnson has taken the nation with
him but that's got to continue the fact
that the opposition and the leaders of
national parliament haven't yet piled in
with much criticism even though the
doubts are there is a mark of how
reluctant they are to do so but he knows
that the decisions that he's making at
the moment could be his undoing the man
who did this all before with swine flu
says that a consensus is vital be
prepared is the number one point we had
a national pandemic plan that had been
put before Parliament we role-played it
in 2007 when I was made health secretary
and two years later there was a pandemic
so that plan upon which we consulted
with the opposition you know there was
there was wide consultation with the
devolved all authorities life is already
changing even without government diktat
but clear leadership remains as
important as ever
Sam Cade Sky News